my name is Daniel Aaron Wisner I  graduated through Hillsdale College in  February of 1955 I have two patents for  the electronic cruise control here is  almost 50 years later and it's still  going among my 13 other patents is the  wide range reluctance tack on which is  used for the anti-lock brake system I  was just a regular design engineer nada  I wasn't hired to be an inventor I had  lots of manners as a kid including dr.  old often ii men especially dr. olaf my  physics professor i was fortunate enough  to have some very good professors who  became manners for me at Hillsdale  College my Hillsdale College manners had  confidence in my success and I was lucky  to be in the right place at the right  time to achieve it